I'm taking over leadership of a team of
six people to I know and for I don't.
When you've taken over leadership,
did you one give a group talk to
meet with each individual and three,
what did you say? Good question.
Yes. Obviously give a group talk.
That's affirmative. You get
everyone together. Hey guys,
my name is bill [inaudible].
I came from this place
I'm here to take over.
Now there's a some judgment calls do
you have to make because you're going to
introduce yourself, but if you're
taking over a well functioning team,
then guess what?
You're not going into revamp everything
immediately cause everything's going
fine. So your hey, I'm happy to be working
with you guys. Looking forward to it.
I know you guys have a great reputation.
Glad to be a part of the team. Awesome.
If you have any questions, let
me know. I'm here. That's easy.
If you're taking over a team
that's not a working well, right?
There's problems and that's why if
somebody got fired and that's why you're
coming in there, you might need to
address some of those things. Hey, listen,
I know things have been a
little off track. I'm going
to look at what's going on.
I'm going to take input from you guys.
We probably need to make some changes.
We're going to do it together as a team.
That's where we're moving from here.
We need to get back to where we're
supposed to be. Boom. Something like that.
And again,
there's gonna be people on that team
that have been busting their ass and
working really hard. And if you go in
there and just disparage everyone there,
you're going to start off
on the wrong foot. So yeah,
have to keep it pretty broad when
you meet the whole group, hey,
this is who I am as to where I came from,
this is what I'm looking forward to.
All that stuff. And then yes. Do
you meet with people individually?
Absolutely. You go around, you
meet with them and when you,
what do you talk to them about?
You talk to them about them.
We talked to them about them.
You want to know about them,
you want to know who they are.
You want to know what their,
what their family situation is, what
their interests are, what's going on,
how they feel about the transitions
that have been taken place.
A little bit of that stuff. It's
not about you, it's about them.
So go yes and talked to everyone. Take
notes, maybe not right in front of them.
So you look like a nerd but you
know you afterwards you go, hey,
bill has three kids.
His wife also works at the company,
he's interested in soccer and basketball,
whatever. You just take those notes.
You know it's actually good before
you take some on over a situation.
If you already familiarized
yourself with us, you look at the,
maybe the HR website at your company
has a picture of everyone so you kind of
know who they are, gives you less
stuff to remember. So there's that
make good first impression.
Don't go in there looking like an idiot.
Don't go in there thinking that,
oh, I just, I'm the boss man.
So everyone has to bow down
and bow down to my superiority.
No, they're actually mad at you for like
the, the thing is they're mad at you.
So I remember one time I was taking over
a small element and one of my friends
was a part of the element
and I went in like 20 guys.
I went in Hay and I walked in,
but I just had a notebook with like five
things I wanted to talk to them about.
And as soon as I walked in, I opened up
my notebook and he's said something like,
you brought a notebook,
you're always squared away.
That's why you're putting in charge.
That's when your boots are.
So like just a little impression of, hey
man, I'm, I take this stuff seriously.
And I would say overall your main
goal when you're meeting your team,
when you're meeting the individuals on
your team is you are looking to build
relationships with the people on the team.
That's what your goal is.
Because when you build these relationships
that's just gonna make your team
stronger, et cetera. Yeah.
I remember the time that you want when
you were on Joe Rogan the first time when
he was like,
hey,
you're the only ones who's ever brought
in note pad yolk and you're like,
just trying to be prepared
to just try to be prepared.
It was good in case there's
anything, you know, you hop,
it comes up to you don't want it to slip
your mind. Yeah. Yeah. That's funny.
And I'm trying to imagine
being a worker and you know,
when you get a new manager,
you know, whatever new boss,
um, you know, they come in.
Yeah. If they're at like
having the individual meeting,
I would dig it and then,
but if they're like taking
notes, I'd be like, wait, why
are you taking notes? Like,
well, how are you going to use this
against me later? Or something like that.
Hey man, how's it going? How
long have you been here for? Oh,
I've been here for four years. Oh,
cool. Do you you married? Yeah. Yeah,
I got two kids. Oh, that's
awesome. That's awesome.
How long have you been married
for? Six years. Like that.
You didn't even know the person.
If I go in there and I go,
how long have you been here and you're
like six years and I write that tonight.
And I say, ah, what? What? What is
your primary function here at the team?
You know what I mean?
If you just jumped right into that.
We're not looking to build a relationship.
We're just looking to find out how I can
use you. Yeah, that's what it feels like.
I mean you said it like Polo, you been
married, you said it like that man.
It doesn't matter how you say you can
say it the most nice polite way ever.
And when you write it down
it's kind of like, Bro,
you going to take all this information in,
sort of do some sort of evaluation for me.
You know,
kind of is what it feels like.
It does feel like that.
That's why I specifically said when
you're having a personal conversation with
the person that you're
meeting for the first time,
you're not scratching it into a note pad.
Now, that being said, if the guy says,
you know what, I've noticed some things
here around here that need changing.
You go,
really hold on a second.
Let me break out my notebook here and
take notes on what you're about to say.
Probably the guy that's a dance, you know,
it's like when you get a micro manager,
you're working for a micromanager.
Bring a notebook. You,
they see you writing stuff
down. They think it's, they,
they're like happy trick anyway.
Yeah.
Cause well because when you're writing
down their stuff saying flips the script,
it's like, it makes it like all
yeah. Yeah. He's taking notes.
It's a part what I'm saying,
you know for sure.
Like he's gonna evaluate like my
opinion. Oh heck yeah. That's good.
Roll in there with the Moog book.
It's like the doctor,
you know when you go to the doctor
and he's asking you, oh yeah,
like all this stuff. You see
them writing down, you know,
and your chart or whatever.
Even though situation is good cause
you want them to go evaluate it later,
whatever. You don't give you a
cure. But same deal, man. Same deal.
Be careful with those notes.
My seat Jack.
Jack Echoes not prepared for
you to take notes on them.
We're not with my personal stuff. How long
have been married? Oh, nine years old,
kid. Nine years. Anyway, you understand.